question eight I don't know if maybe you
found it fine
question eight in exercise 7s written a
product rule okay so if you'll find with
this question then just carry on but
otherwise you can move pay attention so
I think it's not that hard so what is
the derivative you get for a portion
rule what do you get
yeah that check out okay
that seems yeah that Spencer that one
unexpected it's um there's AB degree 1
versus degree - because you're
differentiating to lose a bedroom okay
so now what we have to do show that the
tangents at the x-intercepts have
opposite gradients and meet at a point M
whose x-coordinate is the average of the
x-intercepts okay so I think one of the
this is a Cambridge thing I don't know
they just really are keen on long
sentences and long sentences are a bad
room for journalism because I have to
understand so let's take us a box I mean
this song is quadratic what kind of a
graft is represented it represents any
kind of all quadratic with roots an
alpha and beta right and that a all it
does is it scales and up or down okay
so therefore concentrations are getting
alpha yeah okay so now that's not to put
together the question from the
information from the question the
tangents at the x-intercepts so here are
my two x-intercepts let's put in the
tangents and you can see because I've
thrown up you know like it's reasonably
accurate you can have something like
this that's pretty close this is this
okay is that about right yeah sure that
the tangents at the exodus have opposite
gradients okay so if this is gradient
five you can expect the in gradient
minus five it does look like a checks
out and meet at a point in whose
x-coordinate is the average of the
x-intercepts
okay so this point and we're expecting I
don't know what it's Y acquittal be so
I'll just call the Y but I'm expecting
this part which are some some textbooks
they use a really weird techy name they
call it an abscess up which just means X
cool they wanted to be the average of
these two so alpha possibility okay so
that's what I'm expecting yeah
so how do I work this out well if I were
to work out a point of intersection I'm
gonna need to know the equations of
these limits right so how's that gonna
work long we've been looking attention
to normals before let's do one at a time
if I want engine to the curb another way
of saying that is it's alpha and I also
know its y-coordinate as well because
it's the intercept its alpha zero right
okay I'm getting both those nice
information because I'm going to need to
know the point and I'm going to need to
know it's Grady as well then I complain
in two point rating form so at this
point at alpha zero the gradient will be
okay so I'm just going to evaluate dy DX
at such a point okay which it doesn't
turn out to be that hard because of the
numbers you get to alpha minus alpha
minus beer so here you've just gotten
alpha yeah
so now I can pop it into a great informs
the equation of the tangent will be Y
minus y1 which is just a zero is equal
to M
there's my gradient outside of X minus
x1 which is now okay all right okay now
that's fine but what was not actually
interested in I'm gonna have to find
number one the grading of his line and
number two where intersects with the
other one so before I go any further
why should I already know the gradient
there it is okay so see now the type of
thing got the other one okay one side be
crazy the other line then I can work out
where the intersect so I want to find
the tangent at not alpha zero but beta
zero right because it's so similar a lot
of its going to pan out exactly the same
the gradient is going to be our first x
to be a minus alpha minus beta so
there's my new gradient so if you like I
can call this gradient one and gradient
two and you can see ones the office of
the yellow that's what they mean by
their opposite gradients okay so I can
say P are m1 is equal to negative M 2 so
that's a bit my opposite green it's okay
alright next step let's work out the
equation okay so it's going to be y
equals and you can see because it's so
similar again I'm gonna get minus u over
there so I've got a beta minus Alpha X
minus okay so now I'm after point of
intersection
fun laughter played intersection and I'm
really interested actually in the
x-value right
I'll never substitute my y's then my
equation will just be next ok so what do
I got
I've got the left hand and sorry the
right hand side here X minus alpha and
I've got the right hand side yeah thanks
now don't forget by the way we said that
this was m1 and this is m2 and they're
just negative each other right so I can
just push let's see if X minus alpha
here right and this will just be minus X
minus meetup just divide it all the way
through okay so now I just clean up here
what minus X plus beta X minus alpha now
want X to be the subjects 2x over there
alpha plus beta over here and there's a
result we're expecting okay so what were
the pieces number one we had to get a
picture of what it looked like so we can
work out what our approach they did you
have to find these two equations and is
this shortcut around that but thankfully
the Android works out quite neatly
because how similar these equations are
and then you have to work out this part
here officer grants business